i'm current davina and this is safe
state gamespot's
big old news show and today for july
13th we're talking about ubisoft's
release dates lily doesn't care about it
cyberpunk 2077 is coming to game pass
and microsoft takes a stance
on cross gen games this is monday you've
made it
beginning of the week welcome
the ubisoft ford event wasn't full of
surprises but
it was full of release dates now to
begin it's battle royale hyperscape
is now an open beta for pc then there
was watchdogs
legion which is coming out on october
29th for pc
ps4 and xbox one it is gonna be coming
out for ps5 and xbox series x
but we don't know when if it'll be the
same date
or what i guess we'll just have to find
out when those consoles are even coming
out
in the first place next up was
assassin's creed valhalla which is
coming out
on november 17th for pc ps4
and xbox one and like watchdogs legion
it's coming to ps5 and xbox series x but
whether or not it's gonna be on that
exact same date or not we
don't know yet both those games however
did have a lot of extended gameplay
which
you can see here on the gamespot youtube
channel so check it out
if your heart desires now aside from
those two games that are coming out this
year the one for this out is far cry 6
which is coming out in february 2021
and you guessed it it's going to be
available on pc ps4
ps5 xbox one and xbox series x
the game is set on the fictional
caribbean island of yara and it features
giancarlo espacito gus frang from
breaking bad the really menacing chill
guy who owned the fried chicken joints
he's going to be in this now if you
missed the ubisoft event you can watch
the whole thing
on this channel along with trailer
breakouts and gameplay demos including
some previews and impressions and
all that jets so yeah a lot of new games
debut on xbox game pass but
that isn't going to be the case for
cyberpunk 2077
cd projekt reds pr said on twitter very
clearly quote
no game pass plans for cyberpunk 2077
end quote
there you have it now there is of course
the xbox one
themed after cyberpunk 2077 but it seems
that the partnership
doesn't go any further than that not
into game pass at least the witcher 3 is
on game pass currently but it did take
four
years for it to get there so there's
still a chance we'll see it
it may not be for a bit who knows we'll
see cyberpunk 2077
is coming to ps4 xbox one and pc on
november 19th
ps5 and xbox series x versions are also
coming
and you'll be able to upgrade to the
next gen versions for free
microsoft and sony are taking two
different approaches to this
next generation of consoles sony's being
a little bit more traditional having
ps5 only games when microsoft wants
games to launch across
both xbox one and xbox series x
phil spencer explained the game
industry.biz saying quote
as a player you are the center of our
strategy our device is not the center of
our strategy our game
is not the center of the strategy we
want to enable you to play the games you
want to play with the friends you want
to play with on any device
on tv the xbox console is going to be
the best way to play console
games now some people think this means
microsoft is holding back what new games
are capable
so they can perform both on xbox one and
xbox series x
spencer responded to this saying quote
frankly
held back is a meme that gets created by
people who are too caught up
in device completion i just look at
windows it's almost certain if the
developer is building a windows version
of their game
then the most powerful and highest
fidelity version is the pc version
you can even see that with some of our
first party console games
going to pc even from our competitors
that the richest version is the pc
version yet the pc
ecosystem is the most diverse when it
comes to hardware
the xbox series x and the ps5 are
launching this holiday
okay that's all for today's news however
there is one more thing to talk about
and that is
the gamespot merch store yes we have one
it has t-shirts and hoodies and a face
mask
and most importantly a skateboard yes
a skateboard till the end of august all
of its proceeds are going to be going to
both
black lives matter and coven 19 relief
so go there take a look at something and
know that your dollar
is going to something worth going to
okay that's all we got for today
i'm curtin divina of course you can find
out everything i just talked about and
more by going to gamespot.com
until next time be well watch those
hands gives thumbs up
like things be positive about things you
like
yeah okay see you later
you